the biggest misconception of being an
architect is most people still believe
that to be able to draw a good floor
plan you actually have to know how to
draw
when the fact of the matter is most of
drawing a good floor plan
has actually nothing to do with
understanding
how to draw
what's going on guys my name is david
tomich and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me today i'm talking
about the fundamental
basics of developing an architectural
floor plan
now as a fully qualified architect here
in western australia i've drawn
many floor plans in my day yet i am a
terrible artist
as you'll see throughout this whole
video starting at the very beginning you
actually have to understand the client's
brief the client's brief is incredibly
important
if you don't know what they're looking
to build if you don't know how much
they're looking to spend
or even if you don't know what time
frame they need to be in this new
property buy
are all things that could lead you
astray if you don't
nail that brief straight away so before
you even put pen to paper
or pen to ipad it's genuinely all about
understanding the client brief and
understanding them as
a person being able to engage with
another individual and understand their
likes and dislikes
in a short period of time is a slowly
acquired skill
that you will develop throughout your
career but once you've mastered the
briefing process you actually be able to
start
the process of designing a floor plan
one of the most
important elements of any floor plan and
any architectural design is being able
to understand the site
so for me personally it's all about
going to that site first
understanding the parameters of the site
the limitations of the site
and any issues that might arise if i
hadn't been there in person
just because we have the liberty and
luxury of google maps
and we can easily just type in their
address and look at street view
doesn't mean we actually understand that
property in any way shape or form
especially if you're working on rural
properties where google maps is
so outdated that it almost isn't worth
looking at when you're on site for the
first time
make sure you take as many photos and
videos of that site as possible
when you actually start designing and
drawing it's going to be critical
because your memory is going to be
jogged and you're going to have to
remember
every single detail so say there's a
giant rock in the way or a tree
somewhere that you need to keep
you really want to be able to look back
at those photos understand
the size the scale the grandeur of all
these items
because not everything is perfectly
depicted in a feature survey
just because this information may be
readily available to you
doesn't mean it's 100 accurate and it's
going to give you the same effect as
understanding that knowledge first hand
so going out on site
is where every architect or any designer
or anybody just looking to
draw a floor plan should be starting you
really need to understand the parameters
as much as possible before you start
putting together any ideas
once you've taken a good walk on the
site it's time to actually sit down at
your desk
and understand the local planning
policies and statutory regulations
it doesn't matter how good of an
architect you are or how good of a
designer you are
if you don't know the local planning
policies there are so many times that
you can get
caught out right at the end of the
project if you don't look these up
straight away
so it may be a very boring and tedious
process that you have to spend one two
maybe three hours if you're not relevant
with that council
to understand their planning policies
and guidelines
but it is genuinely something that can
completely change
the final product of your design to give
you an example if it's in a heritage
restricted site
potentially you can only use bricks as
your staple material
or maybe they have a very heavy
landscaping policy
that they want two or three giant trees
planted on that site
if you go ahead and design this
beautiful timber frame
clad house with absolutely no
landscaping
that entire design could get thrown out
the window and be an
absolute waste of everybody's time and
money so understanding the fundamental
principles of that planning policy
and the restrictions to that block could
mean
the difference between a good design and
one that will never get built
now most of the time clients will
actually tell you what they want
most clients nowadays give you a
pinterest mood board or some sort of
photographic collage
of images mashed together of what they
truly like
so it's a good starting point as an
architect to understand the client's
brief
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't go
out and do our own precedent research
now obviously to become a qualified
architect you have to do a lot of
history in architecture
and you learn about all the greats in
architecture
however having said that this doesn't
have to be your primary source
of architectural inspiration yes the
greats are very inspirational and they
are the greats for a very particular
reason
however i'm personally finding that
there are many many talented people out
in the world
that are just exuberating architectural
flair
confidence and just incredible designs
and have
never been recognized for their work i
follow so many different pages on
instagram
on twitter on pinterest on youtube of
just different architects and designers
putting together what they genuinely
like this is usually where i draw to for
my inspiration i can go onto my
instagram page
scroll for days and days and days until
i find
a genuine collective series of images
that i think will best
suit the collective palette of what
we're trying to create
now i usually try and break it down by
project and by room
so i will do a very basic analysis at
the start of what the project should
look like
overall as a whole and then i'll start
breaking it down
internally now that we've broken down
the site we've understood the brief
and understood some of the precedents
that might influence this project
it's actually time to start diagramming
usually what i do is get out my ipad and
start sketching some very basic
diagrams like i said previously i'm a
terrible artist it is not what i'm good
at it is not what i'm known for
nonetheless i still do a lot of
diagramming at the start to really get
my brain
onto paper as quickly as i possibly can
so i'll start by diagramming the site
understanding the solar parameters
understanding how the wind flows through
that
site and referring back to my original
site visit i'll look at where
potentially the best vistas are how the
neighbours properties
interact will that neighboring property
be affecting any area that i'm
critically attached to in some of my
original design concepts
will most of my living spaces be
completely overshadowed and be useless
as a result these are all simple
diagrams that can be sketched within a
matter of minutes
if not a matter of seconds depending how
rough and quick they are
they don't really need to make sense to
anybody
but yourself so it's all about
understanding
the principles of the site and what can
and what cannot be achieved
once i understand the fundamental basic
principle of a layout
of what this site might actually
encompass and where the garage might be
located to the street
how the main living residence interacts
with the sleeping quarters
what the landscaping and what the actual
environment looks like
then i genuinely move into the 2d and
the 3d software being archicad for me
personally
i usually start an archicad with some
generic mapping of the site
understanding
the actual contours and then plotting my
diagrams onto it
this is where i begin understanding the
site in 3d
and understanding how this might
actually affect
the building in its grand scale and size
i'm constantly switching between 2d and
3d at this point
creating the elevations simultaneously
with the floor plan
now this isn't something that most
architects do
nor most people do in general this is
something that i found to be quite
unique to myself
i'll quite often start designing the
floor plan and then all of a sudden stop
jump to that elevation start designing
that elevation and let that elevation
influence and inspire the rest of the
design the best part about working in 2d
and 3d is
it means you can quickly draw sections
understand spaces understand volumes and
height
understand how the flow of the building
really works
you can fly through the model itself and
you can also understand
light in a very quick and easy manner
solar studies are something that i do
all the time in early days and early
stages
to understand if an overhang needs to be
bigger or shorter
how that environment needs to interact
if a deciduous tree needs to be planted
and all these simple elements that are
learnt through years of experience
the biggest thing about an architectural
floor plan is it's never truly finished
it's only finished when you stop working
on it as an architect you can continue
working on a floor plan forever and
continuously manipulate and change it
a hundred different variations of the
same floor plan can be adapted
and manipulated until the perfect floor
plan is actually
never created there is always something
new happening in architecture that's
going to change how a floor plan
is drawn originally that could be
something as simple as a planning policy
changing
or construction techniques changing
entirely it could also be so fundamental
that our understanding of solar passive
principles might change in the near
future
based on how we live our lives so even
though you might finish off a floor plan
and go this is the best thing ever
just remember that a floor plan is never
truly finished
and you will always be able to improve a
floor plan anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and make
sure you smash the like button as well
the like button helps with the youtube
algorithm helps more people
see these videos helps more people
interact and communicate down below in
the comments
and it helps me understand the type of
content you like to see but like i said
that's enough of me for today
so i'll see you next monday